gracias por darnos la oportunidad es de
aquí específicamente bienvenida por las
minnesota a dos minutos donde sucedieron
los
desgraciadamente brutal asesinatos a
nuestro ior floyd
hablando en sentido general desde mi
punto de vista hay un retroceso
histórico con relación después del
asesinato de la muerte de dios floyd
primero si reconocemos que aquí en
minneapolis hubo avance y tiene que ver
con el lograr que se condenarán de
manera justa
a los que perpetraron ese asesinato
a esos policías pero si lo miramos del
punto de vista nacional a nivel de los
eeuu hay un retroceso los crímenes de
odio han aumentado
hay un momento
grandísimo de de la brutalidad policial
según una investigación estatal reciente
aquí en minneapolis la policía de
minneapolis
se comprobó
dentro de la policía
sigue apuntando a abusar y discriminar y
tomar a la fuerza al negro o sea que
vemos claro que aparentemente hay un
avance pero de manera subterránea
según la investigación vemos que no hay
un retroceso también con una
administración baiden y vemos que todo
lo que se prometió
independientemente que trató
de incentivarlo todo quedó en escena lo
que estamos hablando que el departamento
de justicia por ejemplo implementó una
prohibición de estrangulación que eso
vemos avance pero a la misma vez
no pasó todas las promesas que se
hicieron en su campaña no tiene que ver
específicamente con bayern tiene que ver
con el sistema que controla la justicia
en los eeuu por tanto hay un retroceso